he doesn't know where he is
the poor guy they tell they're talking
about his son he's walking off to Jazz
is that the music they played in the
room I mean Jesus Christ play his exit
one more time it's one of the greatest
things I've ever seen with the jazz
music I thought that was dubbed in no no
no the fact that this is the real music
playing as this guy leaves is the
craziest thing I've ever seen talk about
the sun setting on the Empire I mean
watch this thank you
boys
[Music]
raising with every person I met with
yeah he's talking he's not even in the
mic
and then he just walks off to Jazz
just some fun soft jazz
for watching The Quiet Storm
you feel bad